Why do we need data standards?
We discuss that as a part of examining semantic interoperability,
but it's useful to consider it more specifically here.
This simple illustration helps to make the differences and ambiguities in representing
healthcare data clear using a seemingly obvious data element, the patient's gender.
Here, system A represents males with a one and females with a zero.
Over here in system B, that is reversed.
The two systems are using the same language of ones and zeros,
so they are semantically similar,
but they cannot inter-operate without some intermediate translation process
that maps one to the other or both to some common representation.
Should you mix data from these two systems without such an intervening curation process,
gender might be impossible determine
accurately for care delivery reporting and other purposes.
Over in system C,
M is used for male and F for female.
System C is semantically different from systems A and B.
It uses a different language to represent gender.
Moreover, system C recognizes that gender may be ambiguous and represents that with a U,
a concept the other two systems do not deal with.
Interoperability between system C and
the other two systems would require a translation from
its language to theirs or a translation of
all of these approaches to a common form, a standard.
Since undetermined gender is not represented in systems A and B,
some accommodation for that would also have to be made,
particularly if the rate of undetermined gender is of interest for research or reporting.
If something is seemingly simple as gender can lead to this much complexity,
imagine what happens with the concept of a patient's diagnosis,
which is inherently somewhat subjective,
can have thousands of possible values and,
as we'll see, can be described at varying levels of detail.
We've got a sense of that in the Applicadia video in the last lesson.
That is why data standards have been developed.
But as we will also soon see,
they can themselves get quite complex and can be problematic as a result.